[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous merci d'être avec
nous dans 100 % Sénat aujourd'hui la
rédaction parlementaire de Public Sénat
vous propose de suivre une audition
celle du professeur en criminologie
Alain Bauer par la commission d'enquête
sur l'impact du narcotrafic en France
une commission d'enquête présidée par le
sénateur socialiste Jérôme Durin et dont
le rapporteur et tétienne blanc je vous
propose de suivre leurs échanges et je
vous retrouve tout de suite après il est
toujours intéressant de revenir dans
cette maison parler de la problématique
du trafic de stupéfiant puisque au
moment où l'État en France était le
principal dealer public du pays avec la
régie française de l'opium qui était la
version Seita des stupes au moment où
non no territoires coloniaux le chemin
de fer de l'Indochine allait champ de
pavau en champ de pavau c'est dans C
cette maison que les parlementaires
radicaux et médecins de toutes origines
et de toutes obédiences ont décidé de
mettre en cause la pratique qui visait à
faire de l'argent sur le trafic des
stupéfiants au nom de problématique de
santé publique et de médecine je vous
renvoie tout ceci au dragon domestique
de feu mon collègue Christian Bachman
qui est l'ouvrage le plus abouti et
hélas inabouti du fait de sa
disparition sur l'historique de la
manière dont la problématique des
stupéfiant a d'abord été considéré comme
un outil naturel de développement de
business et de commerce et pour tous
ceux qui ont vu les 55 jours de Pékin je
voudrais le rappeler qu'il s'agit d'une
œuvre de pure fiction et que la première
coalition internationale de l'histoire
du monde entre des pays qui ne s'étaient
jamais fait que la guerre avant et après
a eu lieu pour imposer à l'Empire du
Milieu la fin de la prohibition contre
le trafic et la consommation des
stupéfiants au bénéfice de l'ensemble
des puissances coalisées qui allaient
des États-Unis au Japon en passant par
la France la Grande-Bretagne l'Allemagne
et quelques autres donc nous avons une
vision aujourd'hui du problème des
stupéfiants qui est une vision pénale il
y a un peu plus de 100 ans c'était fort
heureusement une vision médicale et elle
répondait à plusieurs problématiques un
l'addiction une addiction massive sur
des populations nombreuses dont une très
grande partie avait été gazé dans les
tranchées en 1418 le préfet de police
expliquait qu'il y avait 100000 addicté
aux stupéfiants à Paris en 1920 et que
c'était un problème majeur qu'il fallait
avoir tra qu'il faudrait traiter une
bonne fois pour toutes et il se trouve
qu'à l'époque les stupéfiants étit un
médicament utilisé pour et si le
Coca-Cola s'appelle coca c'est pas juste
pour faire plaisir c'est parce que
l'essentiel de son de sa compos i comme
le vin Mariani qui fut son ancêtre et
dont le brevet a été volé par les
Américains au détriment des Français
était un produit purement stopifiant
basé sur la cocaïne alors certes pas
exactement traitée comme celle qui est
vendue actuellement mais qui avait
effectivement des effets dit bénéfiques
pour toute une série d'activités
notamment de haute
intensité ou de ou dans en altitude nous
avons une relation donc avec stupéfiant
beaucoup plus complexe beaucoup plus
difficile a traité est beaucoup plus
incompréhensible que celle que nous
avons depuis la loi de
1970 qui a totalement modifié l'approche
de la question des stupéfiants en France
pour des raisons pénales alors que
jusque-là la question médicale avait été
considérée comme essentielle nous avons
donc eu des phases de traitement de la
gestion des stupéfiantces là je parle de
la consommation accessoirement de la
production et de l'Exportation puis du
trafic qui ont amené à des modifications
majeures d'approche donc de culture
une culture médicale puis une culture
pénale pour répondre à un un ultimatum
américain du président Nixon euh qui
impliquait que nous arrêtions de
submerger les États-Unis de production
de très bonne qualité mais qui posait
unun certain nombre de gros problèmes ce
qui explique d'ailleurs l'apparition du
narcoties bureau enenceite de laadea à
Marseille et donc si vous voulez avoir
une idée à peu près précise de
l'évolution du temps avec des
docufctions qui n'avaient pas encore ce
nom et bien vous regardez borsalino enco
pour comprendre ce qui a été carbon et
Spirito s'imposant euh et créant le
premier kiste criminel français à
Marseille et puis la French Connection
expliquant ce qu' a été la
l'industrialisation du trafic et euh
l'effet imprévu secondaire pervers de la
loi de 1970 qui ne sachant pas faire le
tri entre consommateur consommateur
dealer et grosre African à créé un peu
comme notre code pénal d'ailleurs une
idée qu'il fallait tout réprimer de la
même manière et donc prison pour tout et
pour tous ça ne marche pas donc nous
sommes dans un processus sans aucun sens
sans aucune cohérence et où nous
traitons en permanence de conséquences
liées à des injonctions contradictoires
qui n'ont jamais fait l'objet d'une mise
à plat par le gouvernement alors même je
tiens à le souligner que les assemblées
et notamment l'Assemblée nationale
l'année dernière a réussi d'une manière
assez intelligente à avoir un dialogue
construit intelligible cohérent sur la
question de la gestion de la
problématique des supervivants le fait
de savoir si on est d'accord ou pas avec
les conclusions est une autre affaire je
précise simplement que le débat a eu
lieu qu'il a abouti à une forme de mise
en cohérence de la manière don vous
pouvez aborder la question et d'un
certain nombre d'outils proposant de les
traités alors je le précise bien moi je
suis contre toutes les adctions donc
j'apparais plutôt comme un répressif
mais quand une politique de prohibition
donne des résultats aussi inverses à
toute politique de prohibition qui est
eu lieu dans l'histoire qu'elle soit
celle de l'alcool ou les autres nous
avons un souci quant à la cohérence de
la politique un une politique de
prohibition ça se traduit par une
raréfaction du produit une baisse de la
qualité et une augmentation du prix en
France nous avons exactement l'inverse
une augmentation de la qualité une
augmentation de la quantité et une
baisse des prix il y a quand même un
sujet et quand une politique de
prohibition aboutit à l'effet économique
exactement inverse à celui recherché
c'est donc que la politique est mauvaise
ou qu'elle est mal appliquée en France
c'est les de la politique est mauvaise
parce qu'elle est incohérente et elle
est mal appliquée parce que bien
évidemment avec le nombre de
consommateurs que nous avons le nombre
de consommateurs réguliers que nous
avons le nombre de jeunes consommateurs
que nous avons et le changement de la
nature des produits par une augmentation
massive du taux de
THC dans les produits de type
cannabisoïde l'arrivée de produits de
synthèse dont certains sont
extraordinairement dangereux nitazè
kétamine et autres autes produits de
fabrication de dans son arrière cuisine
ou dans son labo la capacité désormais
avoir des relation directe du producteur
au consommateur par la
surmultiplication des champs de
production ou des petits Labau chimique
à petit à petite zone de chalandis le
développement massif de la consommation
dans des zones qui sont passées de la
banlieu à l'aglo et de l'aglo à la
petite ou à la moyenne ville tous ces
éléments là accumulés montrent que la
politique s'il y en avait une de lutte
contre les stupéfiants est un échec
conceptuel structurel et opérationnel
donc il y a un souci générique qui
nécessite de reprendre le problème
depuis le début un qui consomme de
pourquoi on consomme 3 comment on
consomme qu'est-ce qu'on consomme et
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
reprendre la problématique d'abord
médicale qui est paradoxalement la plus
simple par la désaddiction y compris par
des mesures ferme de des addictions
jusqu'à la politique de lutte contre les
grands trafiquants et notamment sur un
certain nombre
d'espac qui nous sont proches et qui
sont des paradis fiscaux ou des
blanchisseuses bien connues des produits
stupéfiant y compris des endroits où on
retrouve beaucoup d'influenceurs
euh qui ont basé leur leur arrière-cours
voilà nous avons ça comme problématique
générale le reste est bien connu l'OFDT
comme l'EDT font très bien leur travail
les problématiques de de connaissance et
des substances et de l'évolution des
substances des zones de développement
des substances de la quantité de
personnes incriminées de l'augmentation
relativement forte des ce qu'on appelait
overdose ou surdose en français
l'arrivée rapide et attendue d'un côté
du captagon et de l'autre du fantanil
vont nous amener à des problématiques
médicamenteuses encore pire que celles
qui ont pu être connues dans des
problématiques récentes euh sur le
détournement du médicament je pense au
médiator en particulier mais ce n'était
qu'un épiphénomène par rapport à ce qui
est face à nous le fait que nous soyons
désormais entourés par deux voire trois
narco-états euh Belgique Pays-Bas il
déteste quand on dit ça mais c'est quand
même comme ça que c'est euh du point de
vue policier en tout cas et même du
point de vue des magistrats qui ne qui
qui n'hésit plus à dire les choses euh
la situation de notre frontière avec
l'Espagne est extrêmement préoccupante
les
problématiques
guyanaise atteignent des degrés
absolument
invraisemblables à la fois
d'acceptation de l'ampleur du trafic
hein puisque désormais une circulaire
pénale avait même prévu qu'en dessous
d'un kil on poursuivait plus qui
inattendu j'avais vu jusqu'à 100 g alors
je je dois dire très honnêtement que le
niveau en grammage de ce qui était
poursuivable ou pas était une nouveauté
je n'avais pas vu que le parlementaire
avait été aussi précis je crois qu'il
avait provoqué une sorte d'interdit
absolu mais bon bon on s'adapte comme on
peut mais là on a face à ce département
en particulier une problématique
particulière et extrêmement inquiétante
de la même manière que sur le craque on
a des situations dans les domes tout à
fait inquiétantes avec un développement
assez
important et des espaces qui sont plutôt
limités sur le territoire métropolitain
Stalingrad et cetera mais
extraordinairement développé dans
d'autres espaces qui doivent être
considérés comme la métropole entre
guillemets puisqu'ils appartiennent au
territoire national donc une situation
générale de de dégradation une
problématique d'augmentation de la
consommation de contournement
d'augmentation de l'intensité des
produits consommés et face à cela des
postures des mouvements des tours de
bras des déclarations des sommations
assez peu de réflexion assez peu de de
contenu et une incohérence absolue entre
la proclamation l'action
l'accompagnement euh et donc un
saupoudrage généralisé qui amène
mécaniquement à à force de vouloir tout
faire sans rien vraiment faire de ne pas
savoir exactement ce qu'on fait donc de
ne pas répondre à la à la problématique
ni de l'expansion du trafic ni de son
intensification ni de l'augmentation des
règlements de compte euh
particulièrement développé par
spécifiquement à Marseille mais c'est
une tradition mais quand on parle
beaucoup de Marseille on oublie de
parler de ce qui se passe autour de
Montpellier autour de Grenoble un peu
autour de Toulouse évidemment à Sevran
et dans la banlieu euh parisienne euh à
Valence euh donc j'ai découvert moi-même
hein que c'était une ville qui
aujourd'hui avait basculé euh de l'autre
côté euh du miroir euh avec des listes
de gens à éliminé des problématiques
inédites dans la manière dont on
s'exprime sur la question et comme nos
amis trafiquants ont pris l'habitude de
nous raconter sur Youtube ou TikTok à
peu près tout ce qu'ils veulent faire
font ou devraient faire euh il faut pas
sous-estimer au-delà du matamorisme
ambiant une problématique de dégradation
forte je veux dire même de
désagrégation de la des
effets de la logique des stupéfiants et
donc de ces effets aussi en terme de
violence de mortalité d'enlèvement de
torture de barbaries
diverses qui amène il suffit d'aller
dans les tribunaux et pas seulement à
bobini pour se rendre compte de ce
qu'est l'apparition d'un état parallèle
qui est un état narco même si la France
n'est pas encore un
narco-état voilà si vous vouliez une
option optimiste ce n'était pas moi
qu'il fallait inviter en ce début
d'année optimiste mais c'est stimulant
du coupti blan va rebondir merci
beaucoup est-ce que vous pouvez nous
détailler un petit peu cette loi de 70
les conditions dans lesquelles elle a
été adoptée les raisons pour lesqu elle
a été et l'influence des États-Unis ah
ben c'est un coup de téléphone du
président Nixon au président de la
République qui lu lui a dit il y en a
marre donc si vous ne prenez pas des
mesures pour démanteler les labos les
réseaux et la distribution il y a eu une
affaire majeure qui était l'affaire je
vais pas dire une bêtise mais Angel vin
je crois un présentateur de télévision
qui avait caché dans vous avez la
version drôle dans le
corneo voilà tout ça est une histoire
vraie alors drôle dans le corniot et pas
drôle du tout vis d'américain qui décide
de faire la lutte à la drogue les
Américains font la guerre à à peu près
tout alors ils la font plus ou moins
bien au terrorisme quand il faut la
faire là ils ont décidé de faire la
guerre à la drogue parce que la
diffusion des produits stupéfiants de
très haute qualité produit par les labos
corsau marseillais français avait amené
à submerger le marché américain et donc
pour des raisons légitime qui est de
lutter contre le trafic et lutter contre
les effets du trafic hein parce que la
la pureté des produits amenait
évidemment déjà un début d'overdose ou
de surdose considérable donc des raisons
médicales en France ont amené à une
politique visant à lutter contre les
addictions et pas à lutter contre le
trafic ce qui avait donné de meilleurs
résultats et par ailleurs prenait en
compte le problème des gazages dans les
tranchées qui est un sujet qu'il faut
prendre en considération on ne savait
pas comment traiter voilà et puis c'est
je veux dire les stupéfiants le cannabis
ou le reste ça a des effets médicaux
qu'il faut pas du tout sous-estimer le
problème c'est que nous faisons tout
trop la France aime les extrêmes c'est
soit tout soit rien et donc on n'a pas
pris en compte les dimensions médicales
et utiles de toute une série médicaments
dont certains sont liés aux produits
stupéfiants les opiacés sont des
produits médicaux comme d'autres mais au
lieu de traiter de la question d'un
point de vue médical le le coup de
téléphone du président Nixon a amené un
bouleversement dans la politique
française et la loi de 1970 qui est
apparu sur injonction américaine pour
des raisons de politique intérieure de
de lutte contre les stupéfiants et
d'absence totale d'action de la France
qui considérait que si on pouvait les
exporter c'était pas très grave c'est un
peu comme les Anglais avec le long
Londonistan tant que les terroristes
djihadistes qui étaient à Londres
commettaient des attentats hors
d'Angleterre on s'en occupait pas il y
avait une sorte de de non dit de dil
d'ailleurs le refus d'extrader l'un des
principaux financiers du terrorisme
international pendant des années n'a
débouché qu'après que des attentats a eu
lieu à Londres et où les Anglais
considéraient que bon bah puisque
c'était comme ça on pouvait faire de la
coopération internationale puisqu'on
nétait plus immune d'une activité
intérieure voilà c'est problèmes
habituels on l'a vu avec le t
entre les Espagnols et l'arrière basse
français donc ce sont des sujets
récurrents le président Nixon a demandé
une injonction elle est connue elle a
été détaillée d'ailleurs dans certain
nombre d'ouvrages sur les relations
franco-américaines et donc nous avons
produit une loi écrite avec les pied
d'urgence n'importe comment qui est la
loi de 1970 qui malheureusement ne
traite pas de manière différenciée des
problématiques différente une
problématique d'addiction qui est une
problématique médicale et qui doit se
traiter par de manières médicale une
problématique de dealer consommateur
mais de petite envergure qui en fait
produit pour lui-même
et se paye pour d'autres et qu'il faut
traiter avec je dirais une sorte
d'aménagement parce que c'est pas Pablo
Escobar et puis Pablo Escobar qu'il faut
traiter comme Pablo escobard loi 70 elle
traite tout le monde de la même manière
dans son intention évidemment dans son
application c'est impossible quand on
arrête 60 80 100000 consommateurs pour
faire du chiffre on les renvoie pas tous
devant les juridictions parce que ça ne
marche pas donc on fait de l'injonction
thérapeutique faut pas recommencer ou de
la saisie avec destruction des éléments
par l'usage de la chasse d'eau voir
réutilisation pour les indicateurs
divers et multiples parce que faut bien
trouver un moyen
de compenser leur activité au bénéfice
de la société bref on a inventé toute
une série de petits aménagements
légitimes et normaux parce que c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne et la réalité
elle la réalité mais on n'a pas tranché
sur décriminalisations dépénalisations
contraventionnalisation
libéralisation le CBD est-il ou n'est-il
pas et vous voyez d'ailleurs dans les
décisions du Conseil d'État ou de la
Cour de cassation une sorte de grande
incertitude générale sur la
problématique de ce qui peut être
médicalement accepté et de ce qui doit
être pénalement réprimé donc ne sachant
pas faire du surmesure nous avons fait
du prête à porter et donc c'est soit
trop grand soit trop petit mais ça ne
taille jamais juste vous avez parlé de
désaddiction comment vous voyez
pratiquement cette une nouvelle
politique sur la désaddiction bah
d'abord l'injonction thérapeutique
pourrait être une vraie injonction
thérapeutique c'estàd une obligation de
soins ceci existe d'ailleurs dans le
code de la santé publique pour toute une
série d'éléments évidemment pour que
quelqu'un se décide la désadiction il
faut évidemment qu'il fasse partie du
programme mais vous aviez avec le
docteur olivenstein marmottant des
programmes extrêmement innovants qui
avaient pris en compte les choses mais
qui sont restés des programmes innovants
perdus au milieu de rien qui était une
sorte d'excuse ah ben on a un truc
là-bas évidemment ça ne peut pas traiter
l'ensemble des je sais plus combien 4
millions de ceux qui ont un jour ou
l'autre consommer du 1 million et demi
qui doit le faire plus ou moins
régulièrement évidemment qu' ne savent
plus traiter la différence qui existait
entre du THC à 1 et demi 2 et du THC à
15 en en intensité puisque il n'y a plus
de j'ai été auditionné il y a quelques
temps par le Parlement belge et on avait
un débat drogue douce drogue Durre alors
j'ai dit d'abord ça existe plus ce
concept a disparu mais en plus qu'on
appelait drogue douce avant et qui pose
des tas de problèmes aux parents des des
années 70 vis-à-vis de leurs enfants par
on peut pas leur expliquer que non j'en
ai pas consommé parce qu'ils en ont tous
consommé ou beaucoup mais qui ne parle
plus du tout du même produit derrière le
mot cannabis et cetera en fait on ne
parle parle pas du tout de la même
substance et de la
même
intensité de la substance et de ses
effets secondaire donc on a un vrai
souci par rapport à la la capacité de ça
mais moi je crois à l'injonction
thérapeutique une vraie injonction
thérapeutique comme l'élément 1 d'une
politique de santé publique d'une
politique de santé publique qui touche
l'essentiel des personnes qui sont
directement victimes parce que ce sont
des malades et je pense qu'il faut que
nous réintégrions ont cette dimension à
la suite de quoi il y a une petite
partie de cette population qui sont des
consommateurs dealers c'est qui
produisent pour eux consomment mais
revendent et disons qu'il y a là une
adaptation à faire notamment avec les
services de de police mais aussi de
santé publique pour avoir une réponse
mixte qui est liée à la réitérance ou à
la récidive comme dans tout processus
normal de pénalité et puis il y a un
problème de trafiquant majeur et donc au
lieu de continuer à essayer de vider la
mer avec une petite cuillère troué et de
de de d'occuper les forces de police à
des missions qui ne servent à rien dont
ils savent qu'elles ne servent à rien et
qui ne produisent rien les reconcentrer
sur on a le même problème avec la
criminalité ordinaire dans mon métier
qui est la criminologie on s'occupe
essentiellement de savoir qui fait quoi
70 % des primos auteurs ne
recommenceront jamais jamais mais on ne
le sait pas la première fois puisque ils
sont primau 30 % vont recommencer au
moins une fois ceuxa il faut les traiter
différemment des premiers mais déjà dès
les premiers il faut indiquer queil faut
s'arrêter il y a donc un besoin
d'expression de l'interdit et
d'expression rapide de l'interdit
contrairement à une idée largement
répandue les courtes peines ou les
mesures éducatives immédiates et rapides
notamment pour les mineurs sont
extrêmement positives elles donnent
d'extraordinaires effets dans les pays
anglo-saxons protestants ou du Nord
parce qu'on intervient vite et on casse
le dispositif rapidement il reste 30 % C
30 % faut les traiter évidemment avec
des mesures renforcées et ensuite on a
environ 5 % qui produisent 50 % de
l'activité criminel vous pouvez pas les
traiter comme les 70 autres % ni même
contre les 95 autres % chacun doit être
traité en fonction du niveau de
glissement vieillesse technicité dans
l'activité criminelle et donc faut qu'on
s'adapte au mode opératoire le mode
opératoire c'est le besoin l'envie le
plaisir le besoin j'ai rien et je veux
quelque chose alors c'est un besoin en
général utile c'est celui qui nous a
permis de passer du statut de sujet
celui de citoyen c'est la révolte
sociale c'est la révolution c'est
l'expression d'une violence contre une
violence plus grande encore cellel elle
n'est pas du tout contanable elle nous a
permis d'avoir un parlement une
représentation démocratique des citoyens
voilà parfois c'est excessif parfois
c'est même extrêmement excessif enfin
grosso modo l'histoire a montré plutôt
la légitimité de la révolte et du droit
la résistance à l'oppression qui est
d'ailleurs dans notre Constitution la
deuxième partie c'est l'envie j'ai envie
d'avoir ce que les ce que quelqu'un a et
n'est pas c'est un effet publicitaire en
général c'est l'effet de la marque c'est
l'effet de la lisibilité de c'est
l'effet des influenceurs c'est l'effet
de l'inutile et du présent mais enfin il
y a en général il y a pas mort d'homme
et puis le troisème élément c'est le
plaisir le plaisir de l'agression de la
possession de la violence sexuelle de la
violence physique de cette augmentation
massive de l'homicide et des
homicidités dont je traite d'ailleurs
dans mon dernier dans mon dernier
bouquin parce que c'est impressionnant
de voir à quel point nous avons inversé
une tendance qui était la réduction à la
violence ultime qui est l'indicateur le
plus stable dans une société he
l'homicide le meurtre l'assassinat nous
sommes passés de 150 homicides à moins
de 2 en 500 ans c'est un gigantesque
succès et en 20 ans nous avons inversé
le processus quand même un petit quand
même un petit sujet qu'il va falloir
traiter or une partie de cette inversion
est liée au trafic de stup pour les
règlements de compte et à l'augmentation
de la violence physique comme élément de
régulation de la vie parce qu'on ne fait
plus confiance à l'état dans sa capacité
d'être un régulateur un intermédiateur
ou un objet répressif puisque comme on
ne sait pas ce qu'il fait et que
lui-même ne connaît que des injonctions
contradictoires ça ne fonctionne pas
donc tout le monde s'engouffre dans les
brèches laissées par l'État en France
puisque l'État en France il a créé la
nation dans tous les autres pays
occidentaux et autres la nation a créé
l'état on a plutôt des états fédéraux
avec c'est le territoire qui fait la loi
et en France l'État a créé la nation
l'État est censé tout faire tout faire à
la place de tout le monde et mieux le
faire que les autres c'était vrai jusque
dans les années 70-75 au moment où
l'État en France a décidé de devenir un
état libéral au sens américain ou
anglo-saxon du terme protestant voilà je
suis rien contre mais c'est un
changement de culture d'État et ce
changement de culture il a amené un
dépérissement de l'État y compris sur
ses fondamentaux vous me pardonnerez de
signaler en quelques instant euh l'état
social l'état médical on l'a vu durant
le covid l'état militaire euh j'ai
l'impression que nous n'avons plus
vraiment d'armée en tout cas du point de
vue de ceux qui la font hein nous avons
une armée échantillonnaire et
expéditionnaire enfin est pas prête à la
défense opérationnelle du territoire bah
l'état sécuritaire une grande difficulté
à gérer le problème des violences et
notamment des violences physiques un peu
partout nous sommes lyonnais tous les
deux je peux vous faire la liste voilà
on lit les mêmes journaux on voit à peu
près ce qui se passe et cetera et cetera
et donc ce dépérissement de l'État bah
il amène à ce que la nature ayant
horreur du vide la violence sangoufre et
notamment la violence criminelle et la
violence criminelle liée au stupéfiants
qui par ailleurs une curiosité en France
et qu'il n'y a pas de crime organisé
centralisé depuis Farid berama le
Spartacus des cités et la mort de jeanj
Colona le dernier parrain du crime
organisé français nous avons une
décentralisation par le Kaïa local
régional donc des frictions des
problématique de zonees de chalandise
qui sont extrêmement difficiles
Marseille en est l'expression la plus
emblématique mais mais on peut en parler
aussi à Lyon et dans la banlieue
lyonnaise et même à une
expansion assez forte dans des
territoires régionaux dont on nurait pas
l'idée alors je parlais de Valence tout
à l'heure c'est pas la ville qui vous
vient naturellement à l'esprit mais vous
pouvez en choisir toute une série
d'autres et d'ailleurs la carte des
émeutes de ce point de vue- là a
ressemblé d'une manière assez forte on
en parlait encore avec Jérôme Fourquet
il y a quelques quelques semaines avec
la carte du développement des points d'î
la carte des 4000 point deal elle est
très intéressante parce qu'elle est
parfois extrêmement surprenante euh
voilà donc ce sont ces élémentsl qui
sont importants et donc la cohérence
d'une politique pour moi pour répondre
définitivement à votre question elle
commence par une politique d'injonction
médicale forte puissante et accompagnée
donc un réinvestissement très puissant
sur la question médicale le
réinvestissement est générique hein mais
celui-là en fait partie deuxièmement une
adaptation aux politiques territoriales
de lutte contre les trafics en intégrant
le fait justement du kaaïda plutôt que
le crime organisé même à Marseille et
puis troisièmement évidemment une un
réinvestissement contre le dealer
trafiquant majeur et surtout le
blanchisseur parce que quand on tape au
fortefeuille c'est encore là que on a
les meilleurs résultats ce que je
voulais dire c'est que laamonde
forfaitaire délictuel c'est une vision
répressive et et que sur les
consommateurs ça n'aura pas d'effet bah
déjà faudra que je lis des rapports
extrêmement contradict sur l'utilisation
de la voilà donc déjà c'est une création
douanière adaptée d'une manière plus ou
moins compliqué mais c'est c'est une
réponse immédiate dès lors que un on
paye ce qui est pas garanti et donc si
on paye pas que se passe-t-il
rien parce qu'il ne se passe rien c'est
ça marche pour ceux qui veulent payer
parce que dans l'autre cas on revient au
système ordinaire qui ne sait pas gérer
les 60 80 ou 100000 gus qui sont
interpellé pour consommation donc en
fait la consommation c'est pas un sujet
c'est c'est pas un sujet c'est pas un
sujet pénal le deal est un sujet pénal
pas la consommation donc il faut arrêter
de s'occuper des consommateurs pour le
gérer d'une autre manière c'est-à-dire
les transférer dans des conditions sur
est-ce qu'on peut vous aider qu'est-ce
qui justifie votre machin en général
d'ailleurs il y a des polyonsommations
qui sont un peu plus compliqué avec
l'alcool et d'autres type de produits
addictifs l' FDT d'ailleurs avait été
créé pour ça he pas de la toxicomanie
mais des toxicomanie on avait eu un
débat extrêmement violent sur le fait de
est-ce qu'on pouvait traiter la drogue
comme le tabac et l'alcool mécaniquement
oui c'est pas une question la question
c'est de traiter le malade on s'en fout
de savoir de quoi il est malade si c'est
une addiction ça se traite comme une
addiction quelle que soit l'addiction
mais il faut la traiter pas seulement en
parler ni pas seulement la la
constater voilà l'avantage de l'OFDT
c'est que on travaille beaucoup avec
Michel Gandillon au Conservateur des
arts et métiés donc c'est un très bon
observateur des problématiques de de
stupéfiant en France et à l'étranger on
s'est rendu compte assez rapidement à la
fois que le territoire du deal le
développement du deal et les
problématiques du lil n'était pas des
problèmes de consommateurs c'est un
problème de réseau de distribution et
qu'il faut taper le réseau de
distribution sauf que le réseau de
distribution il l'importe de moins en
moins et il autoproduit de plus en plus
je il va y avoir un moment où la France
va devenir exportatrice alors je sais
pas si c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise
nouvelle du point de vue du commerce
extérieur mais en tout cas la capacité
nous avons à modifier les conditions
dans lesquelles on peut produire une
partie des produits entre guillemets
naturels et de plus en plus produits
chimiques les labos nous ramènent à
l'avant
1970 bien j'avais une question sur le
dossier coffre une des difficultés que
nous avons repéré aujourd'hui et c'est
la capacité des réseaux puissant
français et
internationaux
à avec l'intelligence artifici iiciel
notamment comprendre comment les
services de police ont
réussis à obtenir un certain nombre
d'informations pour les pour les les
mettre en difficulté et les
juger ces éléments là qui sont éléments
techniques sont souvent dans le dossier
procédural h par les avocats et par une
étude très précise du dossier on arrive
à sair ce qui s'est passé une des
réponses ça peut-être le dossier COF
c'est-à-dire que autorité poursuivante
n'indique pas dans le dossier pénal de
manière transparente les conditions dans
lesquelles les informations on été
recueillies qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
vous êtes très attaché à la protection
et des libertés individuelles un cé suis
attaché à la au fait que la défense
existe et et ce pays qui a beaucoup de
retard du fait du très faible nombre de
ces
euh instructions et du trop grand nombre
de ces enquêtes préliminaires qui
n'offrent aucune garantie sur à peu près
rien et dont la France qui se procramme
défenseuse des libertés qui n'a même pas
réussi à afficher la bas
corpus toujours pas nous sommes tjours
pas un pays d'Abas corpus 2024 est une
interrogation permanente non je crois
pas que ça soit le le problème d'abord
parce que c'est pas l'intelligence
artificielle qui va résoudre ou ne pas
résoudre les choses l'intelligence
artificielle accélère d'abord elle est
pas intelligente elle est très
artificielle elle le sera un jour mais
c'est pas le cas elle accélère
simplement des processus qui passent
pour l'instant essentiellement par des
informateurs et des indicateurs
plus ou moins payé plus ou moins
rémunéré plus ou moins manipulé et plus
ou moins manipulateur comme on le voit
chaque fois qu'un policier un douignier
ou un gendarme est mis en cause pour des
livraisons contrôlées euh dans des
conditions qui ne satisfont pas toujours
à juste titre les magistrats donc euh je
crois pas que le le secret de
l'instruction finale au moment de la
partie je dirais jugement euh doivent
empêcher l'accès à la défense au dossier
euh de l'accusation euh au contraire
même je pense simplement que il y a un
certain nombre d'éléments qui peuvent de
par la loi prévoir et c'est d'ailleurs
le cas l'anonymat d'un certain nombre
d'informateurs mais pas des
informations quand un un l'utage d'un
certain nombre d'outils disons qui
relève plutôt du monde du renseignement
dans le cadre de procédure judiciaire
avec le pseudo informateur X27 c'est
déjà largement le cas et ça ne donne pas
beaucoup accès à la défense euh dans la
manière dont elle peut euh gérer ce type
d'affaire enfin le nombre d'erreurs
procédural qui amène à la libération de
trafiquants ou de criminels du fait de
l'encombrement massif de nos
juridictions de faibles moyens notamment
des greffes euh du fait que les
magistrats n'arrivent plus à s'en sortir
tellement ils ont dossier à traiter est
un problème bien plus important que le
fait de cacher des éléments à la défense
la défense est largement pourvue en
faute de procédure sans qu'on ait besoin
en plus de lui cacher le contenu des
dossiers voilà qui est clair
et vous peut-être pass al nos collègues
mariearlette Carlotti et Catherine conco
nous ont rejoint Marl Carl merci je suis
désolé pour Marseille oui non mais ça on
est habitué on est habitué d'autant que
je vais revenir un peu sur Marseille euh
finalement c'est pas n enfin c'est pas
démoralisant que vous dites parce que
vous avez dit quand même qu'en 70 avec
un coup de fil de Nixon on a pu arrêter
tous les dégâts qu' avait fait la
frenche avec les labos de qualité qui
était à Marseille Grandé de très grande
qualité qui était à Marseille donc ça
veut dire qu'il y a s'il y a une volonté
politique bien sû avec une loi qui donne
certainement pas satisfaction mais qui
est sortie d'un coup de téléphone et
d'une volonté politique et c'est bien ça
qui nous importe à nous dans ce dans
cette commission d'enquête c'est de de
porter derrière une volonté politique
pour attaquer euh pour attaquer ce sujet
alors il y a l' haut du spectre moi qui
m'importe beaucoup mais c'est même pas
là-dessus que je vais vous poser une
question c'est sur la question du
traitement médical et des addictions je
sais que vous êtes pas médecin mais vous
avez quand même fait référence à quelque
chose que j'avais lu quand j'étais très
jeune d' olivenstein qui a écrit il n'y
a pas de drogué heureux et il y avait
des expériences qui étaient en cours
notamment à Marseille par le docteur
Prat qui qui menait ces expériences je
sais pas si on s'en souviens bien moi je
m'en souviens pas trop peut-être que
vous les avez en tête mais est-ce que
ces expériences qui étaient quand même
assez liberté TER malgré tout sur
certains plans parce que il disait qu'il
y avait pas d'acro à la cocaïne et
cetera la drogue était pas la même à
l'époque elle ne est-ce que vous pensez
qu'on peut s'inspirer des propositions
qui ont lieu qui étaient à titre
expérimentaux qui n'ont jamais été
vraiment soutenu ça c'est ma première
question même si vous êtes pas médecin
donnez-moi une piste là-dessus et
l'autre question c'est concernant les
les petits dealers de quartier vous
disiez tout à l'heure une courte peine
pour les mineurs c'est c'est très
efficace Mo courte peine très rapide
d'accord c'est pas la courte peine c'est
la cassure la cassure pard d'accord
préciser parce que moi je vois tellement
des des jeunes qui sont peut-être pas
des mineur d'ailleurs qui ont un
bracelet qui remonte le survê pour qu'on
voit le bracelet ça leur donne au
contraire donc j'ai besoin de précision
sur ces deux points oui alors pardon si
je réponds au f à mesure d'abord oui il
y a eu beaucoup
d'expérience aucun bilan
aucun autant le rapport
perfite juste avant 1981 avait fait en
20 volumes le plus beau et le plus
impressionnant bilan de l'état de la
criminalité de la délinquence de des
problèmes urbains de un diagnostic
absolument remarquable qui n'a provoqué
ni pronosti ni thérapeutique bon mais au
moins céta
fait après 81 on a eu un certain nombre
de propositions qui ont été réalisées
sur certains un nombre important de
secteurs mais qui ont amené une
problématique complète de
ne pas se montrer trop
complaisant parce que il y avait une un
procès en incompétence et
en
philobanditisme qui s'est arrêtait après
l'affaire action directe les attentats
ont créé les conditions d'un retour à
l'ordre au majuscule et on est revenu à
un projet à peu près intelligent qui
était des citoyens libres dans des
villes sûres coloc 10 de ville peinte
issu anciennement du rapport bonne
maison alors c'est à peu près tous les
15 ans la gauche a une une épiphanie
elle elle découvre parce qu'elle est aux
affaires de la plupart des collectivités
territoriales que cette question doit
être traitée et d'ailleurs c'est assez
intéressant parce que c'est une gauche
Janus alors je dis ça avec facilité
parce que j'en ai connu beaucoup j'étais
collaborateur de Michel Rocard pendant
très longtemps ils étaient extrêmement
rationnels et normaux entre au sens de
la normalité de la prise en compte du
problème au niveau local et arrivé à
Paris une transformation avait lieux et
on avait des négationnistes culturels
c'estd en fait le problème n'existait
pas c'était une invention de la droite
alors ça évidemment ça pose un problème
c'est que ça construit l'opposition sur
le thème 1 voilà la France c'est le pays
de négation minoration éjection un c'est
pas vrai de c'est pas grave et tro c'est
pas de ma faute ce qui fait que le
citoyen lambda pour qui c'est vrai c'est
grave et il fallait bien trouver
quelqu'un qui s'en occupe décide de
s'adresser aux extrêmes parce qu'au
moins les extrêmes lui donnent une
réponse certes elle n'est pas bonne mais
il y en a une et puis surtout elle
commence pas par dire que c'est pas vrai
ce qui est quand même un vrai problème
quand vous le quand vous le subissez
tous les jours c'est un sentiment alors
qu'en fait nous vivons un climat c'est
pas la même chose sentiment c'est un
truc évaporé le climat c'est ce qu'on
rencontre tous les jour que ça soit plus
ou moins grave c'est un peu plus comme
les gens qui n'aiment pas l'obscurité
vous avez le droit de vous moquer deux
mais vous pouvez pas penser que ça
n'existe pas la reconnaissance du réel
est un élément majeur donc dans mon
métier c'est une science clinique on
fait un diagnostic et le diagnostic doit
être partagé on le fait assez peu
ensuite on établit un pronostic il doit
être discuté
évidemment si on a pas de diagnosticque
c'est complexe ensuite on a un droit à
une débat thérapeutique qui peut être
extrêmement disputé et on s'engueule
nous avons le pays des meilleurs
thérapeutes du monde sans diagnostic ça
donc marche pas terrible terrible et
c'est valable pas seulement pour les
questions criminelles ou le traficque de
stup donc le vraie question qui existe
c'est quel bilan on a de toutes ces
expériences à marmottant et ailleurs et
alors je peux vous en
citer elles sont anciennes il y en a qui
survivent ici et là mais pas de bilan
pas de proposition le seul qui a tenté
vraiment un travail de fond c'est la
mission de l'Assemblée nationale l'année
dernière sur la
question de la dépénalisation enfin je
vais le faire brutalement voilà on a
chez nous une revue à l'intérieur de
notre centre de recherche au CNAM qui
s'appelle politique des drogues où
cohabite alors à peu près tous les
points de vuees les répressifs comme moi
c'està-dire le problème n'est pas la
libéralisation mais la désaddiction la
désaddiction c'est c'est une mesure
visant à s'en sortir c'est pas une
mesure en disant allez-y youi vous voyez
ce que je veux dire mais qui dit c'est
pas un sujet pénal c'est un sujet
médical mais l'injonction fait partie
des moyens médicaux on peut vous donner
des injonction à des tas de choses vous
vaccinez par exemple pour prendre un
exemple pas si lointain donc
l'injonction comme un élément de
politique médicale élément structurant
d'une politique de réponse au fléau de
la consommation et par ailleurs de
réponse au réseau et au trafic dans cet
ordre là pas l'inverse voilà donc ça
c'est une réponse à ça et on pourrait
faire un bilan d'ailleurs Sénat a tous
les moyens de faire un bilan des
expériences menées pour les politiques
de
désaddiction avec tout ce qui a été
utile et tout ce qui était totalement
farfelu parce qu'il y a eu des choses
très farfelues vous avez raison hein
mais c'était valable aussi pour toute
une série de mesures des années 70 mais
justement le bilan c'est fait pour faire
le tri entre ce qui était utile ce qui
aurait pu marcher ce qui aurait pu être
généralisé ce qui aurait pu être modulé
ce qui aurait pu être proposé et puis ce
qui n'avait aucun sens et qui s'est
terminé comme voilà c'est comme les
politiques de santé publique en matière
de psychiatrie je l'idée de fermer les
centes fermé pour dire qu'on all les
tout réglé en milieu ouvert à amené le
désastre de la psychiatrie nationale les
psychiatres ayant eux-mêmes participé à
leur propre auto extinction mais ils en
sont revenus donc on peut avancer en
faisant le bilan qui est neutre de ce
qui a été fait deuxièmement il y a une
série de propositions et de dispositifs
qui peuvent parfaitement fonctionner sur
la base de ce qui a é bien
fait et qui avait donné des résultats et
à marmotant et ailleurs puisque il y a
eu des bilans régionaux locaux de
subventions
publiques il y a quelques années mon
collègue Sébastien Rocher a été financé
par une mutuelle pour
faire des enquêtes d'auto-incrimination
où les auteurs d'actes délincant
expliquaient pourquoi ils le faisaient
bah c'est pas inintéressant de demander
aux gens pourquoi qui décide de devenir
des délinquants ou des criminels
notamment des gens qui étaient dans le
trafic de stup enfin pour ce qui est de
la réponse pénale alors elle n'est pas
liée aux trafiquant de stupéfiant en
tant que tel elle dit simplement que
dans mon dispositif de 70/ 100 primo 30
secondo et 5 tout hyper productif le
moment où on décide de casser le rythme
du la carrière criminelle du glissement
vieillesse technicité criminelle de la
progression criminelle c'est le moment
où on la casse le plus vite possible le
plus rapidement possible et de la
manière la plus rapide possible et c'est
pas avec un bracelet c'est pas avec un
isolement un moment où justement on a
plus de téléphone bref un moment où tout
d'un coup on est face à soi-même il y a
un accompagnement qui dit euh vous va
falloir s'arrêter tout de suite parce
que voilà et ça ne va marcher que dans
70 % des cas pas 100 %. et ensuite ça
remarchera dans 30 % plus ou moins vite
et à la fin il restera les 5 % sur
lequel on peut mobiliser massivement les
forces de répression
pénale pour isoler 50 % de l'activité
criminelle pour 5 % des auteurs vous
imaginez la reconcentration de moyens
sur le noyau dit dur alors
entendons-nous bien les 5 % c'est une
représentation c'est pas les mêmes 5 %
quels que soi les types d'activité
criminelle je précise pour tous mes
collègues qui vont regarder ça et qui
vont dire oui mais tu n'as pas précisé
que avec la note méthodologique de 27
pages qui accompagne tout statistiques
qui se respectent donc je le fais pour
dire que oui je sais mais pour vous
donner cette image la reconcentration
des moyens sur le noyau dur de
l'activité criminelle de l'activité
dincante de l'activité stupéfiante elle
a des effets elle a des effets
simplement on ne laisse pas perdurer
l'emmerdement quotidien des deux dealers
qui sont en bas de chez vous parce qu'on
est en train de remonter la filière et
que pendant ce temps-là on s'occupe pas
des deux qui sont là on s'occupe des
deux qui sont là mais d'une manière plus
intelligente que d'habitude on sature le
terrain parce que ça c'est important et
de revenir à une police de présence
visibilité proximité qu'on a oublié al
c'est pas la police de proximité je
précise bien ça n'a rien à voir police
proximité ça marche dans les états
fédéraux où le maire est le patron de sa
police et décide de ce qu'il fait là où
il a envie de le faire c'est une police
qui sature le terrain c'est pas une
police d'intervention qui vient de temps
en temps mais on peut trouver des moyens
et les adapter y compris en terme de
répression et de sanction rapide
efficace limité dans le temps mais qui
ne fait pas durer
117 interpellations
90 présentations au juges et au dernier
moment nul ne sait pourquoi tris enfer
parce que ça n'est c'est
incompréhensible pour tout le monde le
système les victimes et les auteurs
c'est donc il y a un souci dans
l'application du dispositif le fait de
vouloir systématiquement trouver des
alternatives à tout ne règle rien s'il y
a pas un contenu à l'alternatif
aujourd'hui l'alternative c'est
classement sans suite injonction faut
pas le refaire enfin des choses qui
n'ont pas d'effet dans la réalité en
tout cas pour une partie importante des
acteurs qui sont ceux qui sont les plus
perturbateurs et les plus hors du
système pénal et surtout du respect de
de règles de vie ensemble que tout le
monde aime le vivre ensemble moi
aussi une question de Catherine concon
je poserai merci merci président merci
al ber pour ses éclairage Cathrine Conon
sénatrice de Martinique sujet prénant la
drogue ça passe par la création de
nouvelles filières de formation de
nouveaux métiers oui parce que ces
personnes que vous destinez à être prise
en charge autrement avec une alternative
avec du contenu qui va faire ça quels
sont ces métiers qu'il faudra désormais
créer amplifier
performer pour que on puisse s'occuper
de ce petit monde parce que c'est pas un
policier qui va le faire c'est pas un
juge ce sera à bon des travails il y a
une telle nébuleuse dans le milieu de la
médiation et cetera donc qui et comment
alors vous savez quand je viens ici
Parlement je suis toujours entemandant
si je suis une espèce en voie
d'apparition ou disparition parce que en
France sur l'ensemble du territoire
national d'homme et th compris il y a un
professeur de criminologie pas deux hein
un pourquoi parce que la criminologie
est considérée comme un outil patate
chaude les sociolâes je parle pas des
sociologues pour qui j'ai le plus grand
respect mais c'est un culte la
sociolatrie considère qu'en fait il y a
pas de mal la société est mauvaise et
les individus sont bon c'est une sorte
de roussoïme étrange euh voilà les
pénalistes pensent que seul le droit va
répondre à cette question et en fait
chacun fonctionne en tuyau d'or sans
jamais se parler ni se rencontrer ni se
concerter et au nom de la sacrinte
indépendance médicale pénale judiciaire
et cetera et puis sur le terrain vous
découvrez subitement que des tas de gens
s'occupent du sujet à marmotant des
acteurs de terrain des associations des
gardiens de prison des magistrats des
avocats des défenseurs des droits mais
ils le font voilà à la petite semaine
dans leur coin et cetera et puis quand
vous leur offrez un un
terrain de d'apprentissage et surtout de
partage de retour d'expérience de
reconnaissance voilà moi j'ai 330
étudiants cette année j'en ai pas deux
je n'ai pas qu'un un doctorat résiduel
pour
répressif extrémistes donc pourquoi
parce qu'il y a une extraordinaire
demande et mes étudiants bah ils sont
très sociaux
très médicaux très pénaux très policiers
très magistrat très avocats très
défenseurs des très journalistes parce
qu'ils ont besoin d'apprendre et de
partager et de comprendre et donc les
espaces existent
paradoxalement les populations concerné
existe parce que ça sera beaucoup plus
de formation permanente d'accompagnement
supplémentaire à ce qu'ils savent déjà
faire ce qu'ils ressentent sur le
terrain que de formation initiale mais
le jour où on créera de la formation
initiale vous aurez des centaines de de
candidat après il faudra créer des
supports d'emploi et là vous allez
entrer dans un débat budgétaire quoi
qu'il en coûte quoi qu'il en coûte plus
ça dépend des jours faut voir enfin vous
connaissez cette histoire aussi bien que
moi mais dans la réalité la quasittalité
des besoins pardon des moyens existent
invisible non coordonnés non concertés
non reconnu non respectés aussi c'est
tout le monde se fout de ce qu'ils font
éventuellement on fait un petit chèque
de subvention si vous créez une par
exemple la France n'a pas de conférence
nationale de criminologie on s'est
jamais rencontré pour parler des
affaires criminelles jamais il m'arrive
d'aller faire cours dans un endroit
formidable qui est k au fleur il y a une
rencontre où des policiers des gendarmes
et des magistrats se parle de politique
pénale comme il y a pas de journaliste
personne ne
s'engueule les flics ne sont pas
fascistes les magistrats ne sont pas
laxistes et on discute et certains de
mes collègues sont invités à venir faire
des conférence qui permettent le débat
sur les conditions dans lesquelles
s'exerce ou pas la politique pénale en
liberté c'est un truc formidable c'est
une annexe de l'école
nationalemistrature donc je n'en dis pas
toujours du bien mais je profite de ce
moment pour dire qu'il y a des endroits
c'est l'école nationale supérieur de
police fait la même chose on a les mêmes
activités assez régulièrement pour la
manière dont on forme les analystes du
renseignement parce que dans le
renseignement il y a aussi le
renseignement criminel c'est pas
seulement l'espionnage international et
donc on fait passer des idées et en fait
il y a d'extraordinaires compétences de
terrain elles sont partout on les
rencontre partout je suis allé l'autre
jour à une
conférence
des personnel d'assistance
psychologiques des départements qui
avait connu un drame parce que une
d'entre elles s'était fait assassiné par
quelqu'un qui était disons plus perturbé
que d'autres mais il y avait des des des
ils étaient plusieurs dizaines on a eu
un un débat d'une richesse d'une qualité
avec des
interrogations la diversité des
expériences mais qui ne sont reconnues
par personne ou en tout cas seulement
dans le petit circuit professionnel du
petit morceau du tuyau où on discute en
fait la la ressource elle est là elle
demande qu'à émerger comme
toujours le lendemain de mon élection
comme professeur de criminologie j'ai
découvert que j'avais 40
collègues clandestin sans papier de la
criminau ce que j'appelle qui exerçait
sous des titres et des noms divers dans
des tas d'université et qui enfin
maintenant qu'ils avaient un point de
référence sont tous arrivés pour dire
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour aider le
conservatoire à se développer moi je
pensais être tout seul en fait on était
40 mais je suis le seul émergé on va
dire donc maintenant il y a un institut
de criminologie à Lille qui assume
totalement sa vision il y a de la
victimologie à peau qui assume
totalement son point de vue il y a de la
médecine légale de très bonne qualité
PSI PSI PSI euh anant et et Ren il y en
a Poitier on commence à voir apparaître
des pôles non centralisé puisque on
narrive pas à avoir de reconnaissance
des carrières parce que c'est ça qui
pose problème à mes collègues ils en
font de la criminaux sans le dire en
attendant que sans que personne ne les
voit des fois que ça leur nuise en terme
de carrière moi j'ai atteint le plus
haut niveau donc avant avant la retraite
bientôt sauf si vous la repoussez
euh voilà mais la reconnaissance du
niveau c'est il suffit de faire une
conférence nationale ouverte ouverte pas
consensuelle ouver
sans journaliste parce que c'est
l'élément perturbateur désolé c'est pas
que je ne veux pas que les médias soient
là c'est que les médias doivent être là
après pas pendant où chacun va pouvoir
enfin se parler de savoir comment on
règle une partie des questions qu'on
vient de voir et vous allez voir à quel
point la compétence du terrain est
exceptionnellement développée en France
et à quel point la structure centralisée
nationale parisienne bureaucratique de
l'État est totalement c'est les c'est
les trois singes en un seul
sourde aveugle
muette vous décrivez un paysage où on a
privilégié de manière confuse maladroite
désordonné une répression tous aimute au
détriment du soin dans dans la réalité
de la consommation des des stupéfiants
est-ce qu'il y a une place à part pour
quelque chose qui échappe aux soins qui
serait de l'ordre du récréatif que je
mets entre guillemets et puis deè
question dans l'approche que nous avons
actuellement si vous vous dites on tape
de la même manière indistinctement sur
le consommateur le consommateur de
dealer et le trafiant y y a-t-il une
solution une voi par la modification de
l'échelle des
peines alors d'abord le problème du
récréatif c'est qu'il peut être addictif
moi c'est le récréatif m'in diffffère
c'est l'addiction qui me pose problème
alors quand c'est un médicament
extrêmement addictif mais qui permet de
résoudre re la question de la douleur ça
ne me dérange pas qu'il soit addictif
parce qu'il est traité d'une manière
médicale sous contrôle médical et pour
régler un problème médical ce qui
explique d'ailleurs les référendums aux
États-Unis où tous était
extraordinairement favorable à la
libéralisation la dépénalisation la
décriminalisation la tout ce que vous
voulez de tout ce qui était justement
lié à des processus médicamenteux liés
notamment au cancer et à des maladies
extrêmement douloureuses et qui sont
considér comme des médicaments comme
toute une série d'opiacés qui sont
devenus des médicaments et qu'on a dont
on a oublié qu'ils étaient des
médicaments comme des tas de médicaments
détournés de leur usage genre des
fintanil je prends pas le Médiator qui
est pas addictif mais qui est dangereux
mais toute une série de médicaments qui
enfin de médicaments détournés d'usage
qui permettent par des mélanges de
devenir des produits dangereux et
addictif donc moi le récréatif pas le
récréatif c'est pas le sujet c'est
l'addiction qui me pose problème et de
ce point de vue-là l'addiction doit être
traitée d'un point de vue médical même
si dans la tête des gens elle récréative
comme non je ne suis pas alcoolique mais
j'en suis à mon 4e apéro sa c'est c'est
une addiction c'est tout j'ai rien
contre l'apéritif mais il y a des
moments où il faut intégrer le niveau
d'alcoolimisation et du risque que ça
représente alors par exemple che dans le
Colorado territoire que je connais bien
aux États-Unis où c'est un référendum
populaire qui a décidé ça l'augmentation
du nombre d'accidents de personnes sous
influence de cannabis ou de produits
cannabinoïdes et cetera ou de
champignons allucinogène a augmenté de
manière massive alors ils sont dangereux
pour les autres parce son des accidents
de voiture mais c'est valable aussi pour
l'alcool et d'ailleurs la plupart
d'entre eux sont aussi alcoolisés donc
pour moi c'est un problème d'addiction
voyez c'est pas un problème de
pénalisation même s'il faut les punir il
y a pas surtout s blesse ou tue
quelqu'un d'autre mais la question elle
est différente donc addic enfin
récréatif par récréatif je le prends pas
en considération j'entends bien la
différence que vous faites mais pour moi
ça change pas ça change pas quant à
échelle des peenes alors si les peenes
étaient effectives et donc si on
appliquait la loi de 1970 que plus
personne ne fait parce qu'elle est
inapplicable oui bien sûr il faudrait
mais déjà faudrait commencer par changer
le texte pour indiquer ce qu'est la
réalité d'un processus qui doit
commencer par le médical et pas le pénal
donc c'est pas l'échelle des peines qui
est l'élément majeur parce que moi je
suis pour que un grand trafrican
responsable de plusieurs centaines de
morts parce qu'il a surdosé un uit s'il
peut prendre 30 ans et sans autorisation
de sortie je n'y vois pas d'incinant je
précise que je suis abolliitionniste
donc je n'ai pas de d'option peine de
mort mais juste en dessous j'ai aucun
problème avec la répression massive des
trafiquants des relleurs des
blanchisseurs et de tous ceux qui
sachant ce qu'ils vendent sachant ce
qu'ils vendent prennent la
responsabilité de la mortalité de ceux
qui le consomment c'est aucun problème
mais c'est pas ça la question la
question c'est pas l'échelle des peines
c'est une question secondaire enfin
c'est pas ça la question initiale pour
être plus précis c'est une question
secondaire la question initiale c'est
quel est l'ordre de priorité l'ordre de
priorité c'est de s'occuper des malades
ensuite c'est de s'occuper des entre
deux les dealur consommateurs et enfin
c'est de réprimer je dire sauvagement
avec la plus grande force de la loi
comme disent les Américains les
trafiquants et ce qui va
avec merci Mar oui excusez-moi
deinvenir juste
je voudrais parler de justement de cela
des gros trafiquants et du haut du
spectre euh les réseaux criminels on le
sait ils font feu de tout bois pour
faire de l'argent ils font de l'argent
sur tout ce qui bouge en quelque sorte
donc c'est le principe ouais c'est ça
d'après vous est-ce quels sont les liens
entre les trafic de drogue et aussi les
autres formes de trafic est-ce qu'il y a
des porosités entre le trafic d'armes ou
le trafic d'être humains par exemple et
est-ce que c'est un traitement
spécifique sur pour suivre les réseaux
sur le trafic de drogue par rapport aux
autres formes de trafic il y a un gros
travail qui est fait sur la question du
terrorisme beaucoup moins sur les
trafiquants de drogue alors en fait dans
les années 60
70 le système criminel et notamment le
système mafieux qui est beaucoup moins
développé hein parce que nous en France
tout est mafieux mais en fait c'est pas
vraiin les mafias il y en a relativement
peu elles sont très puissantes mais en
France on a du crime
organisé qui avit tenté d'avoir des
relations avec la mafia mais qu' en a
relativement peu dans la réalité le
système était très sectorisé chacun
avait sa petite spécialité et
puis après l'apparition de l'andrangeta
et de la Camora ça a tout changé il y a
eu une modernisation massive et donc
tout le monde fait tout il n'y a plus de
spécialités plus par exemple vous prenez
les centres de
prostitution le long de la frontière
espagnole ce sont des centres de
prostitution et de distribution de stup
désormais on est
multiservice les réseaux de blanchiment
d'argent à 90 % servent à la frautete
fiscale ce qu'on appelle l'optimisation
fiscale dès lors que vous avez un truc
offshore quelque part il est illégal
dangereux et devrait être interdit point
ça ne sert qu'à la fraude sur ces tuyaux
se
branche plein d'autres choses le
blanchiment la
rétrocommission l'argent du terrorisme
c'est très petit évidemment l'argent des
stupes AL l'argent des stupes c'est
estimé à vu né tout compris trafic est
stup 5 % du PIB mondial et 20 à 25 % des
dépôts et à peu près 70 % 50 à 70 % des
offshore cumulativement pas en rythme
annuel parce que c'est assez difficile
d'en faire quelque chose puisque la
lutte antiblanchimement fonctionne quand
même plus ou moins bien plus ou ou moins
bien parce que les cryptos ont créé un
nouvel espace
de liberté au blanchiment mais
aujourd'hui tout le monde fait tout en
fait pour des raisons que vous avez
parfaitement indiqué c'est le gain et
donc si je peux faire ça et en même
temps faire autre chose et rapporter
plus à la fin pourquoi pas et nous avons
d'aujourd'hui une intégration en fait le
crime et notamment le trafic de stup
c'est le modèle le plus abouti de
l'économie de marché intégration ver
verticale intégration horizontale
investissement dans la recherche et
développement développement des zones de
chalandise petite incentive pour le
petit personnel seule la gestion de la
concurrence est plus définitive que dans
le commerce
traditionnel très bien dans les
questions que nous avons posé vous
pardon non vous avez dans les questions
vous a posé on vous a parlé de
l'hubérisation du traffic et
vous avez fait quelques propositions
notamment
et l'identification enfin l'identité
numérique vous pouvez détailler un petit
peu tout ça bah nous avons grâce à
François premier à qui je tiens à rendre
hommage depuis 1539 un état civil qui
nous permet d'avoir une identité je
crois que vous appelez Étienne blanc et
si je regarde votre numéro national
d'identité Vous êtes un quelque chose
quelque chose quelque je ne donnerai pas
l'année voilà et puis voilà et c'est
votre numéro c'est votre identité on
sait que vous êtes né c'est où vous êtes
né le mois où vous êtes né et puis par
la suite de votre vie ce numéro va
permettre de savoir toute une série de
choses de votre vie sociale et au moment
d'une éventuelle disparition la plus
lointaine possible on pourra même savoir
comment et dans quelles conditions vous
vous êtes disparu parce que le
l'identifiant du l'hôpital ou du médecin
légiste ou bref va permettre de savoir
ces élémentsl et donc ça nous donne une
idée qui permet d'avoir une analyse
démographique de la vie des individus et
du fait qu'on est tant de millions
d'habitants dans tel condition avec un
âge moyen qui une natalité qui baisse et
cetera et cetera et quand on a ouvert
l'espace numérique pour des raisons
étranges on a décidé qu'on a'urait pas
d'identité numérique parce que c'était
une atteinte à nos libertés c'est un peu
le concept de on va créer des autoroutes
mais pas de code de la route
ou le Far West sans
shérif or le seul moyen d'avoir une
garantie de compréhension de l'ensemble
de l'activité numérique notamment
illégale de la rageosphère des trolls
des des des
euh des agresseurs euh euh des hurleurs
euh des menaceurs euh des dingues euh
qui s'expriment sur Internet comme si on
était en pleine liberté et qu'il n'y
avait aucun risque c'est de garantir non
pas qu'il n''est pas de pseudo mais que
leur identité numérique garantissse le
fait qu'on sache que pour avoir accès à
Internet et ben leur première adresse
c'est
etienne.blancfance.gouf.fr faire et que
tout le reste ne puisse découler que de
cette adresse
là quels que soi les 27 pseudos vous
allez décider d'utiliser du genre Gon de
la Croix Rousse bon parce que ça va
permettre de résoudre une partie
importante de l'excès de violence et de
trollisation et de rageosphère sur un
espace que nous n'avons pas voulu
réguler et que nous ne savons pas
toujours réguler ceci est donc aussi
valable pour les services faire sur
Internet dans le cadre de l'ubérisation
ou en commandant sa pizza on peut aussi
se faire livrer sa dosette ou ses
dosettes parce que tout ça passe par des
messages qui eux-mêmes passent sur des
réseaux qui d'ailleurs contrairement à
ce que tout le monde raconte sont
beaucoup moins sécurisés qu'on l'imagine
parce que dès lors que notamment les
services de police gendarmerie décid de
s'y mettre vraiment bah on sent bien que
voilà hein on n'est pas exactement dans
ce qu'on croit et que les les
dispositifs peuvent être contournés ou
Cass et fort heureusement d'ailleurs
pour l'instant d'ailleurs le jour où on
passera au quantique on est à peu près
sûr que plus aucun système de
cryptographie ne pourra résister à quoi
que ce soit ce qui est à la fois une
interrogation une inquiétude et une
satisfaction ça dépend de quel point de
vue on se passe mais en contrepartie on
a le plus grand mal à identifier
l'auteur on on casse les messages mais
on a encore plus de mal à identifier les
auteurs parce que ils utilisent des
identités numériques qui ne sont pas
obligatoires al le fait d'avoir une
identité numérique est un élément qui
peut
parfaitement faciliter ça n'empêchera
pas tout mais ça va réduire massivement
l'ampleur du développement notamment des
réseaux de contournement de distribution
donc je rappelle que par ailleurs il
n'empêche pas les points de Deal il se
rajoute au point de Deal et au lieu de
résoudre une partie du problème de la
nuisance de proximité vous avez nuisance
de proximité plus le livreur à la maison
ce qui est pas
terrible vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
pardon j'ai coupé vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure c'est en tapant au portefeuille
qu'on est efficace qu'est-ce qui fait
défaut
aujourd'hui au code pénal au code de
procédure pénale sur la poursuite contre
le blanchiment qu'est-ce qui fait défaut
dans l'organisation de nos services le
mixte
judiciaire service douaniers services
fiscaux comment voyez les choses bon il
a fallu les attentats de 2015 et 2016
pour enfin avoir une coopération
antiterroriste efficace entre services
qui ne se coopérai pas beaucoup pour des
raisons à la fois légitimes à la
protection des sources et pour moins
légitime c'est à moi c'est pas à toi
pour des problèmes de judiciarisation
aussi car partie du renseignement
disponible n'arrive par des voie
impénétrable celle du du Seigneur sans
doute euh et donc il y a un même enjeu
pour la coopération stup que pour la
coopération euh terro mais à condition
de s'occuper des choses essentielles de
ne pas noyer l'activité antistupéfiant
dans le le le le le consommateur du coin
donc il faut réorienter en donnant plus
de moyens l'face est une bonne idée
quand tuas un réemballage de l'idée
précédente qui elle-même est un
réemballage des Gires qui elle-même
voilà on a on n pas manqué d'idée on est
meilleur dans les idées que dans
l'application c'est le drame du pays et
c'est valable pour la police ou la
gendarmerie ou ce que vous voulez que
que pour le plupart des services publics
mais en tout cas on ne manque pas des
moyens le fait d'avoir une incitation
forte et un outil puissant euh qui
permet de donner des résultats y compris
sur les cryptos moi je regarde avec
beaucoup d'intérêt les résultats je
travaille beaucoup avec les nopid aux
États-Unis mais aussi avec les les
services fédéraux alors moi c'est plutôt
l'antiterrorisme mais du coup on parle
un peu de tout quand on est en réunion
je vois les nouveaux outils de suivi des
cryptomonnaaies c'est extrêmement
efficace et ça démontre que en fait
quand on veut on peut identifier qui a
pris quoi et où ça va quitte même
d'ailleurs à le faire disparaître de
temps en temps aux grand dâes des
opérateurs criminels et après tout je
veux dire une arrivée
soudaineh d'une recette extra budgétaire
dans notre pays ne freine mal à personne
notamment pour financer des gens pour
s'occuper des problèmes
médicaux une question complémentaire au
fil de nos auditions on nous a parlé des
techniques les plus récentes euh les
crypt on nous a aussi parlé de de
techniques beaucoup plus anciennes et
rudimentaires type Awala ah oui bien sûr
est-ce qu'il y a des des des façons de
s'en prémir parce que ça a l'air d'être
plus compliqué à gérer pour la puissance
publique bah d'abord il faut gérer des
problèmes auxquels nous avons nous-mêmes
donné la main c'est-à-dire les centres
de transfert d'argent non contrôlé dont
même il fut un temps la poste était un
opérateur bienveillant de la même
manière que on pouvait transformer de
l'argent liquide en virement pour payer
ses loyers puisque tout ce qui tombe du
camion ne finit pas uniquement dans des
loisirs hein il y a une dimension
sociale aux petites mains du frafic
qu'il faut pas sous-estimer ça permet
aussi de payer le permis de conduire ça
permet de payer les loyers ça permet de
payer des tas de trucs beaucoup plus
créatifs ou en tout cas auquels on ne
pense pas et où nous avions toute une
série d'opérateurs qui pour des raisons
d'activité naturelle de business
considérrait qu'il fallait pas regarder
nù venait l'argent et où il allait et
donc par exemple dans le secteur deshlm
vous aviez trois éléments indicateurs
d'une crise rotation vacances
impayé/ash paiement en liquide qui
étaient des éléments qui permettaient
quand le taux de rotation s'accélérait
que le taux de vacan grandissait que le
taux d'impayé croissait vous aviez une
crise dans votre secteur HLM et par
ailleurs quand le pourcentage de
paiement en liquide ou sous mandat
devenait trop important c'est donc donc
les modes de règlement des loyers
changaient de nature ce sont des
indicateurs fiables stables comme les
indicateurs médicaux des urgces qui sont
plus fiables et plus stables que le
nombre de cûps et blessures volontaes
enregistrés par les services de police
ou de
gendarmerie parce que tous ne le sont
pas tous ne sont pas déclarés mais tout
le monde va aux
urgences donc il faut toujours se doter
de plusieurs outils dont certains ne
sont purement pas sécuritaires pour
avoir une vision plus plus précise de la
réalité comme nous avions fait des
enquêtes de victimation euh pour avoir
une vision plus précise de la réalité
euh alors que les dépôts de de plaines
ne suffisaient pas ou les mains
courantes ne suffisaient pas avoir une
une un un état de ce que les gens
subissaient vous découvrez par exemple
que on est mieux informé sur les Briis
de véhicule et la manière dont votre
rétroviseur a été cassé parce que vous
avez besoin de déclarer aux assurances
que sur les violences intrafamiliales
hein 67 % dans l'un 9 % dans l'autre et
donc quand vous avez que 9 % de
déclaration de violence intrafamiliale
régulière récurrente les les gens vivent
ensemble c'est un peu plus important
qu'un rétroviseur sauf qu'on s'est
jamais occupé de l'un et on s'est
beaucoup occupé enfin on ne séit c'est
un processus lent Mitou est arrivé la
civise est arrivé sur les questions
d'inceste et cetera mais on se rend
compte du retard nous sommes en 2023
2024 pas 1923 1924 hélas donc c'est
c'est un sujet qui est simplement
mécanique je dirais mais tous les
processus en question sont connus nous
les avons aidés facilité pour des raison
de business nous pouvons parfaitement y
remédier ceci dit les banquiers Lombards
ça date de Philippe
Lebel et ils ont été très utile à Lyon
oui et vous avez parlé des divergences
européennes vous entendiez quoi par ce
divergenence Belgique Pays-Bas versus
les autres mais sur
quelle libéralisation euh libéralisation
de la consommation et puis de tout et
sur la poursuite bah il y a pas de
poursuite
de facto qui a pris le contrôle qui
prend le contrôle des coffee shop en au
Pays-Bas la
mafia parce que le problème n'est plus
de faire de la prohibition c'est de
prendre le contrôle du réseau de
distribution les organisation
criminelles savent toujours où trouver
l'argent qu'il leur faut en
Californie le grand problème qui est
aujourd'hui vécu c'est que les
pharmacies du cannabis ça s'appelle
comme ça sont aujourd'hui contrôlé par
les
criminel tous les petits gérants ont été
éjectés ils ont le contrôle a été voilà
c'est donc il y a toujours un moment où
le dispositif pêche par le
réinvestissement criminel pour prendre
le contrôle de quelque
chose sur et donc les Pays-Bas d'un côté
mais nos amis belges sont en grande
difficulté nos amis espagnols les
portugais ne savent plus à quel sens
voué par rapport à leur politique de
décriminalisation dont ils sentent à la
fois les difficultés et les excès
toujours un moment où tu vis l'effet
pervers de l'excès qui a eu lieu et donc
tout le monde se rend bien compte que
quand on on n'anticipe pas la
problématique et la cohérence d'un choix
et ben on a un sujet il y a un État
américain qui a tout décriminalisé en
stupéfiant tout qui vit aujourd'hui une
crise médicale sanitaire majeure parce
que le monde entier vient chez eux
puisque tout est autorisé donc tous les
excès étant autorisés tous les effets
excessifs se retrouvent là-bas et donc
vous avez un sujet qui est que comme
c'est pas un état fermé par c'est un des
états des États-Unis ils sont en train
de se poser le problème du surcout de
gestion des overdose surdose criminalité
et cetera dû à l'importation massive de
consommateurs de produits qui ne sont
même pas autorisés dans les 37 autres
États qui ont plus ou moins
décriminaliser dépénaliser
contraventionnaliser ou libéraliser la
production de divers types de
stupéfiants et je parle pas seulement
des des affaires de de gestion de
stupéfiant pour des raisons médicales où
là il y a un vrai enjeu mais le reste
j'entends bien ce que vous dites sur la
libéralisation de la consommation et je
voulais parler sur la poursuite des
réseaux sur le la poursuite contre le
blanchiment est-ce que mais on poursuit
plus rien mais qu'est-ce qu'on veut
qu'est-ce qu'on peut poursuivre on
poursuit encore les trafiquants en
Belgique et au Pays-Bas en en Belgique
oui aux Pays-Bas quasiment pas qu'est-ce
qu'on poursuit c'est quoi
l'incrimination quand quand la drogue
arrive sur un port et on saisit et on
poursuit ah on saisit et on poursuit
mais quand elle arrive sur le port et
quand on la saisit sur le port oui le
problème c'est que comme la consommation
est autorisée après la consommation
c'est rau bah oui mais si la
consommation est autorisée il faut bien
qu'il y a un réseau distribution les
coffee shops sont autorisés donc on peut
importer légalement et les réseaux de
distribution non autorisés je pense
notamment sur la cocaïne est-ce que
selon vous et l'harmonisation européenne
est suffisante sur ces sujetsl est
inexistante
ation pas de politique déjà chez nous
elle est pas très cohérente avec les
pays de l'Union européenne il y a de
très grandes différences pays du Sud
pays du Nord et nous au
milieu j'avais une dernière question sur
ce qui se passe à Dubaï au Maroc en
Algérie où viennent se réfugiés les
trafiquants qui ont pignon sur rue qui
se constittu un patrimoine et selon vous
c'est un sujet absolument essentiel
aujourd'hui pour lutter contre le
narcotrafic et quelles sont les mesures
que vous pourriez
préconiser bah alors l'Algérie et le
Maroc ont des relations complexes avec
la France qui n'est pas le cas de Dubaï
ou des émirats avec les Émirats il est
possible d'avoir une une relation
directe carré opérationnelle parce que
ils tiennent
beaucoup de plus en plus d'ailleurs à
leur
réputation dans les autres cas la
question est relève du remord colonial
et elle est extraordinairement
compliqué à traiter pour des tas de
raisons diverses y compris d'histoire du
processus de de de consommation de
constitution euh des régions interne
enfin il y a il y a il y a une histoire
coloniale ancienne et compliquée à
l'intérieur du pays concerné le Maroc
par exemple mais pas seulement et puis
avec l'Algérie encore plus qu'avec le
reste parce que tout est hypersensible
et euh que c'est assez compliqué mais
eux-mêmes ont de temps en temps eu des
politiques euh répressives majeures j'ai
noté par exemple depuis 1 mois que la
Turquie était passée
d'une comment dire indolence locale à
une répression féroce contre un très
grand nombre de réseaux de trafiquants
de stupéfiants alors pour des raisons
que je ne traiterai pas ici et et de
cette manière-là mais pour des raisons
diverses mais notamment de de rejet
d'une concurrence externe par rapport à
leur organisations criminelles internes
il n'y a pas que de la bonne vol volé
dans Caire en tout cas c'est assez
impressionnant de voir le retournement
de de tendance et la le processus
répressif extrêmement puissant qui a été
entamé en Turquie donc il est possible
de voir la même chose à Dubaï en tout
cas c'est très possible à Abu Dhabi
c'està-dire au niveau central des
émirats à Dubaï ça nécessite un peu un
peu de travail puisque Dubaï est un
opérateur qui ne dispose pas de
ressources naturelles il ne dispose que
du
commerce donc c'est
compliqué de gérer ce type de problème
parce que le réinvestissement et et la
blanchisserie est un sujet qui existe et
qu'on ne peut pas sous-estimer voilà
c'est comme expliquer tout d'un coup que
les voitures diesel s subventionné et
l'année d'après que le gazoil s'est mal
voyez ça provoque des réactions un peu
compliquées quand c'est un peu brutal
voilà et ben c'est la même chose dans
les relations
internationales mais ça manque
d'agriculteur à Dubaï alors dernière
question de cette audition passionnante
Mar merci président est-ce qu'on sait
mesurer la prise en main de ces mafieux
réseau on les appelle comme on veut peu
importe sur l'économie locale rachat
d'entreprise de gré ou de force et
cetera est-ce qu'on sait le mesurer dans
notre pays quand on veut oui quand on
veut quand on fait un groupe local
d'intervention qui fait une enquête
approfondie qui utilise les douanes le
fisque le renseignement l'intelligence
artificielle Bery euh le rignement
douignier qui est très puissant et dont
on parle pas
suffisamment et parfois le renseignement
extérieur quand les relations passe par
du crypto et cetera on a des idées
d'imprégnation local local voilà d'un
point de vue global on a des estimations
mais quand on veut vraiment savoir quel
est l'état d'imprégnation du crime
organisé qu'il soit stupéfiant mafieux
ou ordinaire entre guillemets bien sûr
voilà pour cette audition de la
commission d'enquête sur le narcotrafic
commission qui doit mettre en lumière
les nouveaux enjeux que pose l'extension
du narcotrafic dans des zones jusqu'à
présent épargnées qui doit rendre ses
travaux au plus tard fin mai 2024 merci
d'avoir été avec nous si vous voulez
aller plus loin je vous propose de
retrouver les articles de notre
rédaction web sur notre site internet
www.publicsenat.fr très bonne suite des
programmes sur les chaînes
[Musique]
parlementaires